Look I might not have as much experience
as you because I'm not super old like you
but I've seen all of the Fast and
Furious movies Lady it's all about
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie they dropped a
new Shazam Fury of the Gods trailer so we'll break
it down there's a bunch of new footage if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos the big news is that James
Gunn will be announcing his new DC slate like
DC Phase one of his rebooted DC movies in the next
two weeks we might even find out about that next
week because he sounds like he is ready to pull
the trigger because I've been all kinds of rumors
about who they're going to recast as the new
Superman Jacob alordi was someone that was thrown
around but then James Gunn came on and was like no
no no absolutely not we haven't cast anyone this
is bullcrap so it just sounds like he's very
eager to lay a lot of rumors to rest which I
think we're all excited about like just announce
what's going on so we know of course it has to be
said that Shazam Fury of the Gods is part of the
old dceu like it's meant to be connected to the DC
EU so there's lots of questions about what's
going to happen to all the Shazam characters
after the events of this movie will they all be
recast or will they continue forward into the
new DC Universe Zachary Levi seems very confident
that he's going to come back just based on recent
events which I'll talk about later in the video
and related to all the Shazam Universe stuff we've
been talking about Black Adam the last couple
of weeks because of the big announcements about
James Gunn recasting pretty much everybody and
them getting rid of the rock with all the drama
of him bringing Superman back and trying to set
up his own little corner of the DC Universe and
like re-center all the DC movies around himself as
Black Adam unsuccessfully now turns out there was
also supposed to be a big black Adam Cameo scene
in Shazam 2. everybody wondering where we're gonna
see Shazam versus Black Adam turns out they were
actually planning on doing it relatively soon but
the rock actually turned them down and didn't want
to be in the movie because it sounds a little bit
like an ego thing like he wanted all this stuff to
be centered around the Black Adam character and be
more about Superman vs Black Adam which is still a
really cool idea but no matter how successful the
movie had been they were never going to completely
re-center the entire DC Universe around the Black
Adam character but just starting with the brand
new trailer footage you see more scenes of the
Shazam characters fighting the daughters of the
Greek Titan Atlas played by Helen Mirren Lucy
Liu and Rachel Ziegler they're based a little
bit on the Greek concept of the Pleiades this
constellation named after the real-life Seven
Daughters of the Greek god Atlas but they're
just three that they're doing in the movie the
whole idea as they say in the trailer footage
like helamiron's character says that they're
trying to take back the powers that the Shazam
characters stole from that or at least that they
feel like they stole from their father because the
Shazam name is actually an acronym based on the
Greek mythology the Greek gods like we're talking
about Wonder Woman's Gods the pantheon that she
comes from one of the characters that they draw
their power from is the Greek Titan Atlas it
sounds like one of the keys to that power is
the broken staff of the wizard Shazam that they
broke during the first movie because you see them
take it from the museum and reform it and use the
power again there's new footage of them fighting
the dragon at the Phillies baseball stadium
remember they live in the Philadelphia area
so most of the time on Earth in the regular World
during the movie is spent in the Philly area when
they're not out on the rock of Eternity which you
see a lot during the trailer or at this place here
where it seems like the daughters of the Greek
Titan Atlas live may be related to Mount Olympus
because we're talking about the Greek mythology
one of the planned cameos for the movie was Wonder
Woman there were a bunch of Wonder Woman cameos in
the upcoming films this year that reportedly they
actually deleted because of all the recastings I
don't know if they've gotten rid of Wonder Woman
in this movie because she sounds like she
was a bit of a throwaway joke the way that
they used her in the movies they might still let
her be in it I think a lot of the teasers in the
post-credits scenes and things that they got rid
of in movies like The Flash movie for instance the
big Superman Cameo during that were mostly because
they were meant to set up future movies that they
never intend on paying off now because of all the
recast things and the rebooting and I don't think
Wonder Woman scene during Shazam Fury of the Gods
was meant to do that so they might still let her
scene be in the movie but you see all the other
dceu footage here they show in the trailer when
he's talking to his therapist his child therapist
because Billy is still technically a child in the
eyes of the law and he's just talking to them
about how a couple years on since the events the
first movie he still feels like kind of a fraud
compared to the other Justice League characters
and reportedly while he's talking to his therapist
he talks about this fantasy that he has about
going on a date with Wonder Woman and they pay
that off at some point in a funny way during
the movie if you look around the doctor's office
here too there's a ton of DC Easter eggs probably
the biggest WTF is the Green Lantern Easter egg
in the background but like there are a bunch of
Wonder Woman plushies there's an S for staro in
the background here referencing the events of
the Suicide Squad movie there's titano the Super
8 from the Superman comics that represents the
letter T he was a chip named Toto that was sent
to space during a test flight and was bombarded
with cosmic rays that gave him superpowers that
Superman fought Way Way Back in the classic Comics
there's several Wonder Woman plushies there's
Batman plushies there's a Batman action figure
there's a Flash action figure but like I said
there's a Green Lantern action figure meaning the
Green Lantern already exists in this continuity
and this is meant to take place in the DC EU like
this is the new timeline like the movie takes
place around the same time as the events of the
Black Adam movie so that the Shazam League doesn't
get caught up in what's happening during the Black
Adam movie like they explain why they don't rush
over to conduct you also notice there's an Easter
egg for the Annabelle doll from the director's
horror movie the Annabelle movie is like he
comes from an indie horror background that's
how he came to the Shazam franchise you notice
when he's flying through the city talking about
how he's been a lousy superhero the past couple
of years to show you different footage of Freddie
Freeman complaining about being hurt by something
and he's wearing another big Easter egg reference
t-shirt it's a Batman and Robin t-shirt but this
time it's an actual bat dressed as Batman in an
actual robin bird dressed as Robin I think the
whole idea with the Black Adam Cameo scene that
they wanted to have during the movie is that he
would have been like a post-credit scene because
they had a big black Adam post credit scene teaser
at the end of the first movie which they also
deleted it wound up being this big deleted scene
uh guys there's six of us and there's
seven Thrones who's who's that for
well whoever it is I'm gonna love them no matter
what because they're an automatic part of the
family he was meant to be the person that they
were going to quote unquote love no matter what
because he's part of the family so to speak too
bad they're never going to pay that off I would
be so surprised though if he does wind up in
the movie and they were just lying about all
that stuff I don't think that's the case though
I think when all the trades were reporting on a
supposed Black Adam Cameo scene not happening now
I think they were being truthful about that like
I think the rock is basically done with DC for
the time being the big thing with Zachary Levi
recently is that he was just spotted with Peter
Safran on vacation over the recent holiday and the
reason why that's a little bit weird is because
Peter Safran is now James Gunn's partner is like
the co-presidents of DC and they're basically
the ones who decided to reboot everything the
reason why Zachary Levi knows him is because Peter
Safran is also the producer of a lot of the DC
movies including the Shazam movies that's why you
see footage of Peter saffron and a lot of the DC
trailers like James Gunn Suicide Squad movie The
behind the scenes footage for the Shazam movies
he's more like the business guy to James Gunn's
creative head James Gunn is mostly focused with
the creative side of the DC movies Peter staff
ran more focused with the money side of things so
everyone was naturally just assuming it was going
to be very awkward if Zachary Levi winds up being
recast after he was posting all these things
about potentially coming back like he seemed
very confident that he would be coming back they
are supposed to do a bunch more promotion for the
movie towards the end of this month like the
director of the Shazam movies said that they
would be releasing another really big trailer in
a couple weeks before the end of the month and
part of the reason why you don't see James Gunn
already announcing what DC Phase One of this new
DC rebirth or DC rebooted movies are going to
be is because they're still releasing all the
upcoming DC movies they had planned to release
this year and they still want to make a bunch
of money on those even though some of the movies
will set up things that they never intend on fully
paying off I think one of the things that happened
after James Gunn decided to reboot everything is
they tried to tweak some of the movies so they
felt a little more self-contained so that they
did not set up way too much stuff that they
weren't going to pay off like originally as
of October last year there were a bunch of other
teasers and post-credit scenes that were setting
up their future crisis on infinite first in the
movies that they wanted to do then James Gunn
comes on they're like okay you know what let's
just like re-edit take a couple of those scenes
out so they don't completely spin off into a bunch
of different movies that nobody's ever gonna see
to be fair though James Gunn did say that not a
hundred percent of everybody in the dceu is going
to completely be recast some of the characters
will come back and that does include some of his
Suicide Squad characters his Peacemaker characters
like with all this DC reboot stuff they're still
planning on making Peacemaker season two James
Gunn is the person who wrote All the scripts he's
going to be directing a lot of the episodes he's
also in the middle of writing the new Superman
reboot movie that they're making as part of DC
Phase One he said it's like the most important
movie they're going to be making as part of his DC
Phase One you want everybody to love whoever this
new Superman is going to be otherwise it's really
hard to build a Universe on a movie that people do
not like but like I said James Gunn making his big
announcement big slate of movies in the next week
or two maybe as soon as next week so make sure you
enable alerts for my channel so you don't miss any
of that of course I will do videos for whatever he
winds up announcing the other big news is that The
Last of Us episode one is starting on Sunday and
I'll be doing weekly episode videos for it like I
do for all the other big series on my channel it
sounds like it's going to be a banger just based
on all the reviews and speaking of Pedro Pascal
crossover like Pedro Pascal into the Pascal verse
the Star Wars Mandalorian Season 3 Trailer will
also be dropping on Monday too so there's gonna
be a whole bunch of stuff coming in the next
couple of days everyone click here for my new
Ant-Man and the Wasp quantumania trailer video
with a whole bunch of new footage for Kang and
Avengers 5 teasers and click here for that
brand new Flash trailer video for The Flash
movie thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!